[Music]
hi welcome to what's new and Android
development tools I'm Jamal a product
manager on the Android dev tools team
and I'm tor I'm the tech lead for
Android studio so we're excited to show
you some of the new features have been
working on inside of Android studio as
you know Android studio is the official
ID for developing apps for Android
before jumping in I just want to spend a
few moments highlighting some things you
might have missed since you last spoke
with you so last year at i/o we launched
Android studio 3.0 and that included
things like a new performance profilers
Kotlin language support adaptive icons
and a new Android emulator with Play
Store integrated plus 20 new features
earlier this year we launched Android
studio 3.1 let's talk about it so
Android studio 3.1 which focused on
performance and quality
we fixed over 800 bugs and stability
issues 40% of our time was fixed on
issues reported by you so thank you for
your patience and feedback now we're
certainly not done with quality we've
heard loud and clear from you that
performance and quality is essential so
we're continuing to invest in that but
even with our focus on quality in
andorra co 3.1 a few bugs slipped past
us and so thank you for those who report
those issue to us to allow us to fix
those issues so in addition to quality
we know that bills feed is also critical
for you so inside of Android studio 3.1
we worked on that so for example when
using D 8 with the sugar integrated we
drove upwards of 60% build speed
improvements on full builds without
caching so that's that's a great
improvement so in addition to build
speed and quality in Android studio 3.1
we looked on a looked on a few different
new features including sequel code
editing support so this has Co
completion and project navigation sort
of using any of the room database API s
re the sequel Lite the api's this should
be a plus for you
so last year we announced Cullen as a
first-class language on the platform and
inside of Android studio since that
point we've been continuing to invest in
the Kotlin so inside of Android studio
3.1 you can not only do Kotlin checks in
the ID but also on the command line so
if you do a lot of automation test with
Kotlin now you have that support built
in inside of Android studio now for
those of you who have C or C++ code
here's also treat for you
we added a C++ CPU profiler and again
allowed you to drill into your C++ code
and understand the performance impact of
your C++ code and of course that's on
the unified timeline inside our
performance profilers and speaking of
performance profilers we also updated
the network profiler so you know that
many of you have multi-threaded network
threads in your app so now you can look
at each individual thread and see the
performance of that aspect and of course
you can drill into the call stack and
see down to your source code what's
happening and of course with each
version of Android studio we try to
include the latest version of
intelligent in there so one of my
favorite features in this version of
IntelliJ is actually this new feature
called a s e-g previewer and what that's
cool is that as some importing and
managing my s e-g assets and converting
those to vector drawables it's very
convenient to be able to double click
back into the source asset to see the s
e-g file so that cams a pop comes along
with the intelligent update and of
course with Android studio 301 we also
worked on some updates to the Android
emulator one of the pain points we've
heard from you is that the emulator is
too slow to boot up so you just saw this
morning from Steph's keynote we we
enabled quick boot and cuckoo boot
allows you to launch the emulator in
under three seconds so you've had a
chance to try that out please do alright
so that brings us to today to talk about
Android CEO 3.2 so our team works
closely with the android framework and
the Google engineering teams to ensure
that all the latest Android technologies
and API is are tightly integrated to
accelerate your development flow so for
example
with Android studio 3.2 you can test and
Vout it and integrate all the latest
Android API is from the P Developer
Preview and as announced this afternoon
we have a brand new app format called
the Android app bundle so the Android
studio 3.2 you can build this bundle and
and of course of time you can void
deploy a customized apk to users using
Google play's dynamic delivery system
and lastly Android studio is a major
component of Android Jetpack and again
Android Bev jetpack is a set of
libraries developer tools and a set of
opinions it guidance to help you quickly
and easily scale to make great apps for
Android now for Android studio 3.2 we
worked on our range of teachers across
east of ailment flow in your process so
instead of you talking about each
individual feature and we actually have
tour give us a demo tour all the cool
features of things you can do inside of
Android studio 3.2 I'll come back and
talk with you afterwards with that story
all right so it's my pleasure to show
you all the new features that we have
built over the last year so the first
thing you'll notice is that we have this
new window on the right it's the what's
new window so in this window we'll be
showing it to you once per release and
we're sort of highlighting the important
things for you to know changes and new
features in that release and if you look
at three - the number one thing that
we're profiling is the new Android app
bundle support so let's get right into
that so the key takeaway about app
bundles is that it lets you package and
upload your app in such a way that the
Play Store can create many different
versions of your app one for each
combination of chip architecture screen
size and even locale and that makes the
download smaller right so in studio all
you have to do is rebuild your app so if
I go to our generate sign APK wizard you
can see there's a new option if now for
generating a app bundle and here I can
sign it and it's really important to
understand that for Google Play to do
this it has to sign your app so you have
to give it your encryption key to do
that so I'm gonna choose to export the
encryption key and note also that it's
not X
sporting it into the bundle okay so if
we look at the little notification here
from the bottom right there's a little
link that we added so you can see where
we stored that key so you can upload it
the UI needs a little work
so we'll tweet that so now that we've
created this bundle file we can take a
look at it
so the apk analyzer also works on bundle
files naturally if you look at this it
should looks pretty look pretty familiar
so dynamic delivery is really really
easy for you to do it's basically you
know upload your key and rebuild and
that's in production today we also are
previewing dynamic feature modules and
so if you look carefully at my bundle
file there's actually this other thing
called article composer that just
happens to be a name I chose for a
dynamic feature in this app that can
compose articles right so how did I do
that I went to the new module menu we
have a dynamic feature module module
type and here it doesn't want to go it's
like oh okay here I basically get to
choose the name of the feature and also
enter target I see that's the phone I
have network issues I've already created
this module obviously since you see it
my bundle file so let me just show you
how it's all wired together so first I
have a new module where we apply this
new special Gradle plugin for dynamic
features we have a manifest in that
module where I can basically say that I
want this to be on demand and we want
the place to refuse it so that it can
build ap case for older devices that
don't support this and in our main app
module we link to these dynamic features
so creating a dynamic feature module is
a lot more work for you you're gonna
have to use the play core library to
react to download installation events
but it's really useful if you have some
large functionality in your app that not
every user is going to want so you can
have your base app be small and then do
the on-demand installation of these
other features one other thing we've
added to the run config dialog
is the ability for you to choose which
features are included when you are
testing locally now to testing download
installation stuff you'll need to use
the Play console testing track all right
so that's dynamic apps let's take a look
at the profiler so we have several new
features in the profiler I'm gonna open
it up and I have an app running this is
the plaid app so the first thing you'll
notice in the bottom left here is we
have a sessions view so you can record
multiple profiling sessions and then you
can go in and sort of compare results
one thing I've already recorded earlier
is a new feature we've added which is
systrace so systrace is this really
powerful profiler it looks at data from
the kernel so I can see what's going on
on different CPUs there's thousands of
tracing events from the kernel that's
being recorded it's probably hard to see
on the screen there's some fade
graduation of colors here to show you
all these events so that's the CPU
tracer I'm sorry that's systrace let's
go back into our CPU view now let's
assume actually let me start these were
all pre-recorded sessions let me now
attach to the current running session so
here's our telemetry view so now I'm
gonna go into the CPU profiler and let's
say I'm interested in recording why my
UI is so slow when I click on this
thumbnail on the right until now what I
would do is click on this record method
trace button on the left and I would try
to quickly press it after doing the
action but what I can do now is actually
trigger it from code so in 3 2 we have
this ability for you to call the debug
method this is a standard STK method
andrew SD bug so I'm telling it I want
to start method tracing here at the
beginning of all and create at the end
I'm gonna say stop at the tracing right
so now then I'm gonna click on the UI
take a look at what happens in the CPU
view so you can see it captured exactly
the range of code that I'm interested in
and I can now drill in and figure out
what's wrong
with my layout inflation so that's the
CPU profiler let's move on to the
network profiler so let me scroll out a
bit so as Jamel mentioned we have two
new features here we have a threads view
so you can see which thread is doing
what some random picture from this app
we are also showing requests and
responses for the network profiler in
the memory profiler our biggest new
feature is the ability to show you j'ni
references and the allocation trace from
the day9 references and last but not
least is our new energy profiler when
they zoom out a bit so the energy
profiler helps me figure out what's
going on with my battery life so if I
take a look earlier in the app here you
can see we have this legend on top and
this is showing me that I have fairly
light CPU usage but it's telling me if
I'm touching the network if I'm getting
location requests if I'm running alarms
and if I have wake locks and if you see
there's this big red bar on the bottom
that's showing there's a wake lock in
effect a wake lock means that the device
cannot go to sleep this is obviously
really bad for battery life right so
let's look at this range and here it
actually shows me the real way clock
names we can see our first wake lock was
alive for about 4 seconds that's normal
but the second wake lock still
unreleased and go on for 50 seconds
that's not good so what I can do is
click on that wake lock and we drill
down to where the wake lock was acquired
you can see obviously this is a bug I
added this is not the plaid apps fault
this is just to just show the wake lock
so the wake lock detector and the whole
energy profiler is new and 3 2 and
hopefully very useful to you all right
so that's it for the profiler let's talk
about the emulator a bit let me stop
profiling alright so here we are in the
emulator
we have the new snapshots that you saw
earlier and we actually have a whole UI
for this so I can see here that my quick
boot obviously looks like the lockscreen
right but I've also recorded a session
in the middle of searching of Google
Maps so I can just click the snapshot
press play and my emulators instantly in
that exact state I also recorded a
snapshot while running the clock so
again if I press play you can see it's
instantly in that state
15 seconds into recording of the
snapshot and recording a snapshot is as
simple as clicking the take snapshot
while you're running your emulator and
then you can bring it back you can see
there's also a special quick boot
snapshot right that's the one that
emulator is going to come back into when
you restart it so if I exit the emulator
right now and bring it back up you
should see that yes you know it comes
back really quickly we've added a few
other features to the emulator so by
popular demand screen recording a lot of
you wanted this this lets you record a
video what's happening along with audio
and we've also enhanced the camera so
let me start the camera
yes yes all right so what we've done
here is we are now feeding the camera
and the emulator sensors you know the
the fiction that you're in this 3d world
here so actually I gotta have to hold
alt key so I can move around in this 3d
scene and this is really really
important when you're building a are
apps and speaking of AR and we have some
support back in the IDE for that so
let's see this is a gltf file and we
have a plugin let me see settings we
have this scene form plug-in so you
heard about scene form in the keynote a
scene from plugin which helps you
preview your 3d models so here's this
gltf file i can go in and import this as
a scene form asset we support gltf files
to support obj files we support FBX
files and so when I run this import it's
going to create a Gradle task for me
which is creating these sfas FB files
that is Korca scene form and then I can
open my SFA file and the important part
here is that we have a viewer tada so
now I can explore what's going on in a
3d sense what this model is doing
alright so that's seen for me let's
switch gears a bit and talk about
jetpack so if you look at the package
names in the editor here you can see
that we have Andrew dot support we have
some v4 some v7 these are super
misleading version numbers right and so
we decided we needed to clean up our
legacy a bit and so we are repackaging
everything from Android support over to
Android X and to help with that
migration we're providing all of our
libraries in both your old name space
and the new space namespace for now as
well as they automated refactoring tool
so let me show you how that works by the
way this also applies to XML files where
you have these class names and even
Gradle files because we are also
repackaging the group IDs and artifact
for these libraries so I go to refactor
refactor Android X it's gonna look
through the code then it's gonna offer
to preview the changes I'm feelin lucky
so you can see here actually let me open
up the get view and I highly highly
highly recommend that you all make
backups and use version control both
preferably before you do this so you can
see that we've actually replaced a bunch
of the code here and it should work but
we are aware of some bugs already in
Seaforth in canary 14 any canary 15 so
we would really like you to try this and
give a sweet feedback on what's broken
so that we can make this working
smoothly for everyone before 3/2 goes to
stable all right
so jetpack is about a lot more than
cleaning up legacy code we are adding a
number of new libraries and one of the
most important ones for the tools anyway
is the navigation library so the new
navigation library does require you to
architect your app for the navigation
library from the beginning so this is
not magically machine learn intelligence
figuring out what your apps doing okay
this is a navigation graph we have
created for this app so let me show you
how the navigation library works the
plumbing underneath it first so I have a
launcher activity i point that launcher
activity to a sort of route layout and
in that layout all I do is I put a
navigation host fragment and this
navigational post fragment will do the
dynamic dispatching at runtime and then
we point the nav host fragment to this
navigation resource file that's a new
resource type that we've added for this
specific library so now we're looking
back at the navigation resource file
it's just an XML file that we have a
nice visualizer for it so let me
actually go ahead and run the app so if
you look carefully you can see that near
my the mouse pointer there's a little
Home icon that tells me that this page
is the start the start destination in
the
I can just go to the title screen
instead and click on set start
destination and when I run again you'll
see that now the app instead starts on
the title screen I didn't change the
launcher activity or anything else all I
changed was the navigation graph so that
tells the nav fragment were to begin
alright so next I'm gonna click the play
button and it does nothing why is that
well the play button is just a button in
this layout right so if you look at this
layout there are two arrows coming out
of it right the first one on top here
has the action play that's one of the
things we want to navigate when the
action play happens we wanted to go to
this page when the action leaderboard
happens we wanted to go over here so
let's go take a look at the code so I'm
gonna drill into the layout by just
double-clicking so here's our button and
I'm gonna jump to the on click handler
for that button it's called on play and
I'm going to uncomment this code so what
we're doing here is we're finding the
nav controller that's from the
navigation library and this is Kotlin so
we have an extension method right there
on the view but in Java you could just
call the navigation helper so we get the
nav controller and we say navigate to
the action play all right so now I'm
gonna deploy that to the app and once
that gets there I can now press play and
you can see it goes where we want so I
can now go back into the navigation
screen and instead of jumping when I
press play instead of jumping to the
register thing I'm gonna have it jump
over to our in-game screen instead so
I'll just make that change notice the
code doesn't change the code just says
take the play action
alright so now when I press play instead
we go right into the game right so that
the routing table is here another thing
we can do is to select this transition
and say you know what I like an
animation on this transition so I'm
gonna choose the rotate cross to tick
animation and again I'm gonna deploy
that to the device and when I press play
now look at the screen you can see it
rotates right
so there's a lot of features in the
navigator that I'm not getting into for
example passing arguments in a safe way
from one screen to another or nesting
graphs I'll just show one last thing
deep links so I'm going to press the
plus button here to create a deep link
and let's pretend for a moment that I
own the google.com domain so if I look
at the manifest file here all I've done
in the manifest is register my activity
with a launcher intent and also I
reference the Navagraha but now let's
take a look at the merged manifest right
this is what we compute on the fly when
you build and we also compute in the IDE
obviously if you look at the bottom here
we create intent filters for you that
are handling this deep link right so you
just put the deep link and you have file
and now your app will respond to deep
links so that's a navigator which is new
in 3.2 let's talk about the layout
editor for a bit so as you can see you
get this nice graphical view of the app
well the reason that works is that we
have a highly visual app here right so
you can sort of see from the outline
what it looks like sometimes you're not
that lucky
but what really helps is you can add
sample data to your app we've had the
plumbing for sample data for quite a
while but in this release we made it a
lot easier to use so first of all I can
go over in the property sheet and you
can see next to the text property we
have this design-time property I'm going
to bring up the customizer
and here I can explore all the different
sample data types we have so for this
one I'm gonna choose a full name I can
also select a widget in the design
surface and if you look carefully
whenever you select something there are
four buttons under it right the fourth
icon is a wrench
that means design-time attributes all
right so I can click on that and I can
also set design time attributes from
here and the reasons the reason it's
important to know about that trick is
that it's particularly useful with lists
so let me open up a blank layout
and drag in a recyclerview and that
looks really unimpressive right this is
what you get with the recyclerview
but now notice that below the recycle we
we have our wrench again so I'm gonna
press it this is our design time helper
and for list views in recycler views we
offer to customize the item list layouts
for you so if I press next I can cycle
through the various list item layout
here so we create one that looks sort of
email list like one-liners two liners
three liners we even have a grid so the
design done helpers should help you make
your layouts look better from the
navigators least the last thing I'll
mention on the layout editor is that we
also have some support for material
theming so here's a pretend compost
window in an email app so we have the
new chip widgets we have the bottom nav
layout you can see the put the sort of
rounded curve and everything I've shown
you so far is in NRC two or three point
two now I'm gonna give you a sneak
preview of a feature for an upcoming
release might not even be 3/3 so I'm
gonna open up a new layout for that and
the problem we're trying to solve is
making animation easier so what I have
here is a a sub class I think of
constraint layout it's sort of next
generation constraint layout which lets
you do motion so I can select my widget
and it has two constraint sets so in the
beginning it's attached to bottom left
at the end it's attached bottom right at
top right so I can play and you can see
we can animate between these two
constraints outs let me actually go and
turn on motion paths so we can see
what's going on so now we can see where
this thing is gonna go now the important
part is I can go in and add keyframes so
I'll add a Cartesian position keyframe
and I will you know we can drag it over
here for example and I'll add one more
keyframe to rotate so we'll set a random
attribute actually I want to do it
somewhere else so that it's more obvious
so I'll add a new keyframe Oh over here
so let's see new attribute and I have to
select it and then we will say rotation
should be yeah 45 is a good default so
you can see now when I'm dragging
through you can see we both rotate and
and shift the X&Y coordinates and the
real power here is when we start
combining these right so here is a more
complicated animation demo you can see
here let me make the timeline a bit
bigger here we have a number of things
happening so at the beginning we have a
number of widgets at the end you can see
we moved the motion layout we've faded
out the Google cast icon and we made the
header smaller so you can see as I'm
pulling through you know we get pretty
fancy effects and this library also lets
you respond to touch events which makes
it a lot easier to to use so that's
motion layout
no promises someone it'll be done but
you know we're very excited about this
and working hard on it
so now thank you
so now if we can switch to the other
demo machine for a second alright so
what you're looking at here is a pixel
Chromebook and the really exciting part
for us is that if I click on this button
down here you can see we have android
studio running on it yeah so we have you
know we have layout editor we have
counting code building works a lot of
stuff works but there's a couple things
that don't work so there's no ADB yet so
you can't run deploy debug you know some
of some of you don't need to debug
you can upload straight to the Play
Store and hope for the best yeah anyway
so I think at this point you still need
to sort of tinker and be very
comfortable with Linux but it's a very
exciting development I think so you know
I look forward to that getting done and
with that I'm going to turn it back to
Jamal - yeah so there's a sighting could
work right exciting stuff
all right so so torque touched on button
all the visual changes were making to
Android studio I also spend a little bit
of time talking about some changes to
the build system that you might want to
be aware of inside of Android studio 3.2
now the biggest change we've made is
supporting the Android app bundle which
you heard about earlier this afternoon
now as you saw and Torsten well you have
a new little drop-down menu in the ID we
can create a bundle and sign a bundle
now if you want a little bit more
control we actually added some
additional flags inside your
build.gradle file and so in this example
you have on the screen here I have
slides perhaps live
slides great all right so all right so
let's example here so I have a new
bundle section and your build.gradle
file and so for instance I have a split
on density of screen density ABI and
language so this is this a few flags
that you can configure to have some
control what's actually inside your
bundle all right so next is Android X
refactoring so tour give you an example
how it works inside the ID and again
what happens from the build system
perspective is that we will convert your
legacy maven dependencies and convert
those to the new Android X namespace
well cache those and use those for
subsequent builds now again if you want
a little bit more control what happens
to your Gradle properties if a few
things we added to your Gradle
properties file and so in this example I
have the enabled and able Jedi fire set
the true this is actually the default
behavior again what that does is to take
sure legacy maven the artifacts and
converts those to the new Android X
namespace and caches those for new
builds now let's say you have a brand
new project or perhaps you say hey look
I have all my in dependencies already
converted to enter Dex I don't need to
step so in that case you can actually
change the swag to false and we can skip
this step and what that would do is
actually maybe to have faster build
speeds when working with Android X
alright lastly d8 and r8 so da is our
new default Dexter inside of Android
studio we actually launched da last year
in Android studio or 3po know we've been
iterating on that and now it's the
default and it's the replacement for Dex
our it is new it is a new optimizer and
shrinker inside the build tools chain
and it's our long-term strategy to
replace ProGuard with r8
somebody excited for some folks
so again to try it out all you have to
do is go to your building
assuming your Gradle properties file and
go to enable r8 set the true again this
is experimental so we do not recommend
you actually publish your app to the
Play Store just yet however please give
us your feedback and let us know how
it's working for you and we'll let you
know when you become stable inside of
Android studio alright so that was just
a few things to talk about in the
Android build system if you want even
more in-depth session we have a whole
session for tomorrow called what's new
with the Android build system
presented by Jerome and Zev I'd also
check out best practices when using
compilers and Android studio
presented by Jeffrey we have a few more
classes as well on Android studio we
have one more called improved app
performance with Android suger profilers
presented by Esteban that's also this
week and lastly we have a class on
what's new with constraint layout and
the Android studio design tools present
by Nicholas and the Android studio
engineering design tools team all right
so before we conclude I wanna talk about
one last topic it's about feedback for
Android studio as many of you know we
release Andrew studio on a series of
release channels ranging from canary
beta and stable now canary is our
bleeding-edge release channel where we
have most of the new work but a little
bit of testing before goes out to you
and then the other enemy our stable
which receives the most amount of
feedback and testing on our end before
it goes out to you now you may say hey
look I can't rely on canary I need to
tout in my production code unstable if
you didn't know you can actually run
canary and stable at the same time on
the App project now when I highlight one
important detail
it's about feedback so the thing is to
early receive feedback on canary channel
the higher chance that is actually for
us to fix it so thing is once we reach
stable with Android studio it's almost
too late for us to fix things we're only
gonna fix very very critical issues even
honestly if you wait to the very end of
the betas that's almost too late as well
so we really encourage you to do the
download Android studio on the Canadian
Channel and give a Seebeck
sooner than later all right to recap and
joys to do it has a range of cool
teachers across multiple flows of
from onboard with Android jetpack
building your first Android app bundle
testing emailer snapshots and
understanding the battery impact of your
of your app with a new energy profiler
from and of course today we give you a
sneak peek of the new motion editor and
some cool tools are on a our
developments and also some cool demos of
Chrome OS support for Android studio we
hope you enjoyed this version of Android
studio as much as we do
all right want a little bit of feedback
on this session so please go to
google.com slash IO scheduled to go some
feedback all right that's it again I'm
Jamal and this is tor thank you for
tener session on what's doing address
video
[Music]